a little bit I don't want my editor to
see this and get any inkling of what I'm
doing yeah I started it a while ago it's
actually a book I abandoned a while ago
and got really down about I couldn't
figure out how to do it and when I was
writing the story of a marriage I I
figured it out I think you do that you
figure out the way into a book and which
was that was had a more comic tone and
it's a I will say it's a time-travel
novel which won't describe it at all
when you finally see it but that's the
best I can do downside to being a
successful novelist wow I can't imagine
one well I think it would be bad to be
like a truly successful celebrity person
that people because I know these
novelists where people get a kind of
cult following and they have some
strange personal attachment to them
because it's so personal to read a book
it's when the most personal art form so
you could become very strange about the
author i think i've done that about
authors but people don't do that with me
you know i'm not that level of author so
I'm at a good place you know people
people will email me and say wonderful
things or or call me up because I'm
still listed but I don't get any of the
weird stuff and that was mad at me no
one's blogging a bad stuff about
for sure it is I mean you talk to it's
hard to say because it's like saying
strawberries don't taste the way they
used to but I have no idea so but you
hear people talk about writing here
Philip Roth talk about it and it's clear
when his first book came out port noise
complaint everyone in America talked
about it you know not just people like
you and me but but everyone that doesn't
happen it's hard to remember that must
could have been the center of the
culture the way it is in Germany still
but on the other hand you look at the
lit blogs online in the book blogs and
you see tens of thousands of people
checking them out every day and you
realize there's passion you know they're
getting angry about stuff they're
getting delighted enthusiastic about
stuff so there's the passion still there
I don't call and thank reviewers I
always wonder that like an you with that
render what does that make their job you
know obsolete if authors are thanking
them for things I know when he reviewed
my book max tivoli in The New Yorker I
was at The New Yorker a couple I think a
month later and I wrote him a note and I
said it was like having an older brother
in high school who tells everyone that
you're cool and not to mess with you and
that it made it so much easier for me
and that was the best I could do I'm i
think i might get a chance to interview
him in the coming months and i'm never
going to change
it's tough as I haven't written my short
story collection there's a lot more gay
relationships but they're sort of young
and they're unformed because I was at
the same time and then the latest novel
there's a there's a gay tension hard to
tell if it's a relationship it's strange
that I enjoy writing about four straight
relationships a little more I think it's
because for something like Max Tivoli it
was already hard enough to write about a
man aging backwards that I just couldn't
complicate it too much but I added a gay
element to it too just because it I'm
curious what makes me most curious
because I don't write a lot of
contemporary fiction it's to set all
these characters in the past and see how
the constraints of their time change it
so that becomes very obvious how gay or
straight relationship would be utterly
different but in contemporary times they
wouldn't be so different because I think
now young people everyone's mixed
together you know it's not like it was a
good way